In Westworld Season 2 Episode 4, Bernard is
dragged on his arse by Clementine, who grabbed
him last episode.
She drags him to a cave that’s “miles”
from anywhere , which means A) Bernard’s
butt must hurt, and B)
there’s a secret here.
Inside, Bernard finds Elsie – last season,
Ford programmed Bernard to capture her, cause
she almost found out Ford’s plans.
Apparently, Elsie’s survived on protein
bars ever since . Bernard frees Elsie, and
she finds out Bernard is host.
She takes the news pretty well that that her
boss was a robot along.
Her curiosity as a programmer is greater than
her fear – so she helps with Bernard’s
brain damage.
They find a secret Delos lab, like the lab
in Episode 1 where drone hosts record guest
data . But this lab is something more – it
has James Delos.
About thirty years ago, James died of a disease
. But his company, led by William, copied
his mind into a robot body – a hybrid of
human and host . The goal was to make James
immortal.
But this human-host is unstable, it breaks
down . So the company keeps burning James
and making a new one, achieving a longer life
each time.
Over thirty years, he is born then dies one
hundred and forty-nine times , having the
same conversation with William over and over.
The imagery of a spinning record and exercise
bike and circular room evoke the loop that
James is trapped in.
He finds out that his wife and kids are dead
over and over.
He’s burned alive over and over, to the
soundtrack of the Rolling Stones’ Play With
Fire.
He had tried to “cheat the devil” and
live forever, but he ended up in hell.
By the time of Season 1, William’s wife
Juliet has died, and he’s stopped believing
in the immortality project – saying “People
aren't meant to live forever” . So he leaves
James to break down, and then the robot revolution
happens so there’s no one to terminate James
until Bernard and Elsie find him two weeks
later.
By then, James is mad and suffering, which
may be the closest he’s been to alive.
Cause one of the big ideas last season is
that suffering makes hosts conscious and free
. So maybe in Jim’s pain and death, he felt
alive for the first time in decades.
So this is part of the Delos secret project
that’s been hinted at all series . They’re
trying to make humans immortal by putting
their minds in host bodies.
But how does this connect to the Westworld
guest behaviour data recorded in these labs
? And whose brains are these?
To clone James, he has an “observation period”
and “baseline interview” – they make
a record of who James is so they can copy
him with high “fidelity” . Westworld is
kinda the same thing.
William says the park reveals who guests really
are , through their choices and sins – and
Delos has been watching.
With this “baseline” data , maybe Delos
can make human-host clones of all Westworld
guests.
And as we see with Jim’s script, these hybrid
hosts are predictable.
Maybe Delos could use this technology to control
human behaviour . This could be Glory – Dolores’
weapon , William’s mistake , the burning
of the species Logan mentions – not human-like
robots, but robot-like humans . We don’t
know the details, but Glory must be something
that combines humanity and hosts, immortality
and control.
And there’s another mystery here.
We find out that sometime round Season 1,
Ford sent Bernard to this lab to kill the
techs and make another hybrid brain of some
human.
Whose mind did they build?
One possibility is Ford – maybe they’ll
bring him back.
But Ford’s death made a point about the
end of the humans and rise of the hosts . Ford
said he’ll live on in his music – he exists
in the code of his hosts like Lawrence’s
daughter and young Robert.
So bringing back Ford as a hybrid-host would
undermine the climax of last season.
Maybe this host could be a young William to
confront old Bill at the end of his quest
– he is told to revisit his past . Or maybe
this mind will be Arnold’s – Ford’s
partner who Bernard is based on.
If they wanna get tricky, it could be that
the Bernard we saw in the week ahead timeline
in Episode 1 is actually Arnold as a human-host
hybrid . Because he’s acting super weird,
and he has flashbacks of Arnold with Dolores.
How could Bernard remember Arnold’s life?
Last season, Westworld showed us Arnold and
made us think it was Bernard – maybe they’re
pulling the same trick this season.
So this hybrid mind might be Arnold’s.
But there is one more complication – what’s
the data in Peter Abernathy’s head.
Is it a copy of James Delos’ mind?
Or Arnold’s mind?
Charlotte said there’s “Thirty-five years
of … data” in there , so maybe it’s
all the guest behaviour and DNA data – that
might explain why Delos needs it so bad.
William and Lawrence see Chinese railway worker
hosts who kill their overseers and use their
bodies as railroad ties.
Chinese railway workers in the real American
west suffered dangerous conditions and discrimination.
So along with colonial India, and Confederate
slavery, Westworld explores real historical
injustice to parallel the treatment of hosts.
It also looks at violent revenge, personified
by Dolores.
Is it justice to kill your masters, or, as
Maeve suggests, does revenge just make you
just as bad as them ? Bill and Lawrence arrive
as Las Mudas, the home of Lawrence’s wife
and daughter.
Lawrence says that his family loves him, but
really he’s “a son of a bitch”, so it’s
kinder for him to avoid his family . This
is similar to William’s situation – he
had a wife and daughter , but he’s a bad
dude, and spent time in Westworld instead
of with them .
The town is controlled by Craddock.
He holds court in a church and brags about
his resurrection earlier – says he’s the
chosen one of death . This annoys William,
because he believes death is final, and people
shouldn’t be brought back . And then Craddock
starts murdering and tormenting the townspeople
– just like William did when he was here
last season.
So Bill is faced with his own past sins, and
this time, he feels some sympathy for the
hosts.
Lawrence’s wife reminds him of the death
of his own wife, Juliet.
So the Man in Black takes on the role of death,
and kills Craddock and his men in the rain.
Showrunner Lisa Joy says this represents washing
away Bill’s past – trying to achieve redemption
. Lawrence’s family thank him for the help
, but Lawrence’s daughter, speaking as Ford,
says one good deed doesn’t erase William’s
crimes . So this season, we’re getting a
more morally ambiguous William.
Last season, he was a villain, but now he’s
trying to make things right.
As Lawrence’s daughter says, “If you're
looking forward, you're looking in the wrong
direction” – William is facing his past.
We see Grace, the woman from The Raj last
episode.
She’s been captured by Ghost Nation, along
with some guests from Season 1 – tourists
who get more than they bargained for.
There’s also Stubbs, captured last season.
He says that while Ghost Nation does kill
hosts, they don’t kill humans.
Ghost Nation takes their prisoners to Akecheta,
who they call “the first of us” . Maybe
Akecheta was first Ghost Nation host created
– we do see him as an early host in Episode
2.
Grace escapes, then Akecheta threatens Stubbs,
and says “You live only as long as the last
person who remembers you” , which connects
to the themes of legacy and immortality with
James.
Then the Ghost Nation hosts disappear – apparently
letting Stubbs leave and meet up with Delos
for the week ahead timeline.
Why would Ghost Nation capture humans then
let them go?
Are these hosts programmed, or free?
Are they protecting humans, or doing something
else?
We still don’t know.
In the end, Grace meets William, and reveals
that she is his daughter, Emily – maybe
Grace is a fake name.
We know from last season that Emily and William
have a difficult relationship.
She blames Bill for the suicide of her mother
Juliet , and Bill says his daughter would
“Probably” like to see him gunned down
. So this isn’t the happiest reunion.
But Bill and Emily seem to have the same goal
– to reach Glory, symbolised by this hexagonal
pattern that appears in Delos labs.
Now that we know about James’ immortality
project, this symbol almost looks like an
infinity sign, or an hourglass tipped on its
side.
William and Grace might need to work together
to reach the mystery at the centre of this
season.
Thank you for watching.
And thanks to the Patrons, including MELINDA
RUBIN, Matthew Athey, isrightkev, Gareth Foot,
and hayburtz.
Cheers.